it's time to babble [ __ ]
[Applause]
live from the Jon Lovitz aah gasps
theater this Hollywood babble-on with
your host Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Applause]
[Music]
it is Saturday 9:00 Hollywood so let's
babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
and I'm Ralph Garman you sold us out
again you beautiful sons of [ __ ] in
the rain yeah there's like a meteor
shower in Los Angeles people usually
just stay the [ __ ] in their bunkers it
is kind of like the end of the world now
once I saw the rain come in one outside
in the house painted dead inside
business quick disclaimer just before we
set down the stage Kevin turned me in
said wow that's not strictly true just
before we came down there's a little
adrenaline rush and we had a
conversation I forgot to breathe and end
the weed at the same time Oh anyway no
no Kate let's talk about the rain I give
me a chance to watch some movies little
feature for the next few weeks here on
Hollywood babble-on quick keV watches
Oscar screeners oh I see so you get the
bulb in your house oh [ __ ] son I'm like
a little girl in [ __ ] American Beauty
with all the rose petal all those
[ __ ] free DVDs hitting Mitch
what did i watch i watched flight do you
have you seen flight Denzel Washington
holy [ __ ] man flight is I'm not gonna
tell you for the whole movie but there's
a thank God yeah yeah you only have
about 90 minutes in it but it has the
opening half hour of that movie is
[ __ ] mind-bending it's really it's
insanely well-done filmmaking but
without spoiling it cuz I'm sure
everyone has seen the [ __ ] commercial
we know the premise Denzel plays a pilot
who has to make an impossible sort of
landing a la Scully when he landed in
the Hudson River right yes like what
sort of the x-files was that I didn't
see the movie just saw the trailer
Scully we got a land in the Hudson I
want to believe I want to believe come
on that's pretty [ __ ] good man it's
what I do you know anyway back to my
review and barely a review man I just
want to talk about the secrets of the
plan you've seen the commercial I'm not
spoiling anything if you haven't seen
the commercial just cover yours about
[ __ ] five seconds and go [ __ ]
plane flies upside down yeah I saw that
okay um spoilers now when that happens
they're not listening they didn't hear
on spoilers oh I told them Fox said they
should figure it out hopefully they were
counting Mississippi's there's the the
plane as I'm watching this I'm like
[ __ ] immediately I go to the
Internet to see if it's true and of
course the internet will never lie to me
no but it says that that is possible
that you could roll the plane and
[ __ ] fly it upside down a jumbo jet
yes now if this is [ __ ] true why the
[ __ ] did I get thrown off that plane man
baby on one side let's just put it the
wings would have tipped a little bit you
know when a guy your size on the other
side of the plane after everything would
have been fine to balance it out I was
watching this movie and I was just
rolled the tear cuz I'm like if this is
possible how how was I left at the gate
you
how it's possible how booze denzel's a
boozer in the show right oh I thought
you were saying I was drunk I was like
no I'm stoned
no I'm saying Denzel can make a turn
because it's all juiced up that's and
but that's the thing I mean again I'm
not once again it proves that with
alcohol all things are possible - I
believe people can get laid
boring people can be amusing and pilots
can fly upside down oh now that's my boy
yes you rock a little bingo before he
took to the friendly skies
boy that's crazy dude it's crazy but
that's that I mean I don't want to spoil
it much but that would have been I think
a really fascinating film if they had
been like look he was able to do this
[ __ ] cuz he was fun Duff and he was just
like let's try no and it would have been
this weird argument for like sometimes
you should fly stones I guess
he's doing a line off the roof well
they're upside down John Goodman's in
the movie and I'm pretty sure he plays
Silent Bob's dad oh really
looks like I'm [ __ ] dealing drugs
it's pretty crazy anyway it's so worth
seeing go check it all right there you
go
there's like heads review for a buck not
a review from John Goodman by the way
he's in every [ __ ] movie this year
yeah he's in wreck-it Ralph is he really
not as well he's the Hobbit I think
coming up he was the girl in The Hunger
Games I mean this guy [ __ ] works all
the time let's just cuz he was really
good with a bow and arrow otherwise he
wouldn't have gotten that part that's
why it's all about their shooting that
sequel as well I saw a picture of that
yeah that Katniss girl jumping in a lake
or since the Jennifer Lawrence yes yeah
you know they told her she was too fat
for that role initially [ __ ] out of here
yeah she's not a fat girl she was
Southwest casting this film
good night everybody said you can look
hungry enough I guess but she said no
I'm not gonna lose weight because I know
there'll be girls watching this film and
I don't wanna give the impression that
you have to be stick thin to be an
actress in Hollywood I'm a healthy
weight I look fine I'm not about to lose
20 pounds normal Wow but the one that
what about us fatties we're still
waiting for our break man like she sit
up for the normies brew like great the
normies win again hello precious
come on that was a big hit why don't we
get one a decade Jennifer Hudson in
Dreamgirls of course you did lose all
the weight after which have you seen
there we go while we're talking about
movies quick mention our evenings
podcast tonight is sponsored by the Dave
School digital animation of visual
effects school in Orlando Florida they
actually will train you there at the
school which is on the back lot at
Universal Studios in Orlando Florida
they will train you in the ways of
computer animation and visual effects so
if you want to get into movies that's a
real good way to do it by the way
because every almost every movie even if
it's not science fiction or
special-effects Laden they use computer
effects so in almost every film and
there are a lot of young filmmakers who
are like hey I know how to do this [ __ ]
but they're like I may not necessarily
know the write a script but I could
piece together like a short film that's
just chock-a-block full of good looking
stuff and they kind of get your way into
the director's chair as well if you have
a movable skill like this they've got a
an amazing one-year training program
that they are offered right now so you
can go to Dave school.com it's the
digital animation of visual effects
schools Dave school.com for more details
and you should sign up and then move to
Florida and you would be the smartest
person in Florida
this Florida's [ __ ] that is a [ __ ]
up state every time you read anything in
the news that is some [ __ ] up story
about somebody eating somebody's face
sir or a girl shooting a guy because he
came before she did if you look last
week they're doing that now [ __ ] girl
shot her boyfriend because he came
before she didn't she was fed up with it
so this one the first time I fair I'm
guessing there was a history it's the
favorite the first eight she's a little
she's a little sensitive like pulling
out weaponry if he shoots his load hair
two shooters where's that rimshot when I
need it you want a rim job stop it
before we get going tonight we would
like to give some shoutouts to people
who've come particularly long distances
and we're celebrating special occasions
a little segment we call appropriately
[Music]
one of these days you're gonna go right
off the ride backwards just ass over how
they died trying to filet the microphone
yeah any other way really
as always we get a ton of these I'm
sorry we can't get to them all we just
picked out a couple and we'll read them
so if we miss yours [ __ ] you but you can
always reach us at HBO podcast at
aol.com here is Matt's email from
Australia Matt from Melbourne Australia
hear that diplomatic immunity
you really really works for any country
Matt writes I'm writing to say on yet
another goddamn Aussie you came all the
way to see you guys tonight in Los
Angeles after 15 hours stuck on a plane
in the economy class Oh Matt I bleed for
you sir I'm celebrating my 40th birthday
which isn't technically until April
[Music]
Australia it's April already right yeah
I got a pre-emptive pass from the wife
to launch eight excuse me I got a leave
pass from the wife to launch a
preemptive birthday strike in LA and
Vegas so Vegas is the next stop sir all
right don't spend all your money here I
would love it if Adam West as Batman and
Bane could wish me a happy birthday and
give me some advice for Las Vegas
thanks for the hundreds of hours of
laughs Matt Matthew you're going to that
evil city of sin and Vice Las Vegas
I personally of course never gamble it
tells the senses and makes
crime-fighting that much more difficult
but could you put $20 on black for me
and I would I would just like to say
that while in Vegas what happens there
stays there so perhaps you're wondering
why you could shoot a man in the mouth
with your gum all right Shawn Gus and
his wife Amanda are you guys in the
house there you go hi guys my wife a man
and I are attending HBO for the second
time tonight we were almost unable to
make it because amanda has been feeling
under the weather for the last week
second time tonight did you do an
earlier show no it's their second time
tonight I was like 6 o'clock I get it
now there's a common there would have
been helpful whatever so it was my
reading that threw you it wasn't the
bale of weed that you smoked before we
got here that's what confused you was my
grammar could you please have the
McDonald's fry girl give a man - some
advice on how to stay healthy over the
holidays and not get sick for our
vacation next month
Shawn bus why why certainly I'm sure she
has a mexico pun intended
hi you should be healthy with the
holidays by eating vegetables and fruits
like apples the apple pie be careful
contents may be high
and french fries are very nutritious
they they feed them to babies this
change met me when I was a baby 25 I
don't care would you like swords with
those Chicken McNugget we have holiday
sausage we have Points area snow cold
for bad children and Santa you don't
want to know how Santa make the thought
thank you so much for coming out
[Applause]
he Lindsay
Christal and Scott will be at the show
celebrating a belated 30th birthday
celebration for my dear friend crystal
she's always been a great friend she
even offered me a place to live when I
moved to California right Steve yes
these yeah come on knock on the door see
you got the Regal Beagle she's had a
tough first half of the year emotionally
physically while recovering from two
broken ankles [ __ ] how did you break
ball crystal
[ __ ] you got hobbled you you took
some money from a loanshark and you
couldn't make the Vig you dirty bird
fell down some stairs at Disneyland one
day that [ __ ] sweet mommy your
license I know that mark now you could
own Star Wars now if you play the cards
right
did you get a settlement anything any
money from them kind word did Mickey
help you Bob does it say in the back of
the ticket if you fall here you're
[ __ ] get the read the fine print I
guess anyway she's on her own feet now
she's had her own she's got her own
house he's got a great boyfriend she
seems happier than she's been in quite a
while well that's nice
can you wish her a happy birthday as
Harrison Ford well certainly [ __ ]
walk downstairs full birthday advice
[Applause]
Brianne hey soos I'm assuming it's a
snooze what Ben Stiller's a dick is that
would you say was your day [ __ ] show
you think this is round quick could you
give a soos some life advice now that
he's 21 as the gay ghost all right Bree
also if Kevin could give me a shout-out
says bree or make or say anything to me
and his creepy sexy voice it wouldn't
take my night hey bring my wife's here
tonight
Wow boo here's what you do when your
birthday hey Zeus you go to massage
place right you find yourself a nice guy
next thing you know you got a pup tent
you say could you fix my pup tank he
says what never mind
yeah is Gina here Gina and Chris already
Chris birthday you're Chris right down
there in front how [ __ ] drunk are you
right now yeah
Gina writes coming the show to celebrate
my cousin Chris's birthday he's a dude
in his 40s he likes video games playing
with Legos and Star Wars sounds like
everybody in this room
Casey couldn't figure it out he's also
single right Gina
that's a hell of a cousin you got there
Chris considering his love for all
things geeky I'm thinking Yoda should
give him some sage birthday advice Yoda
would you like to impart some birthday
advice and job you get from me dude you
can take birthday pass that game
Chewbacca will give me a hand beat Chris
and celsa hi guys my girlfriend's Elsa
and I are going to attend your show to
celebrate her birthday although I have
listened to your show for a long time
myself has never had the pleasure well
it's a hell of a birthday for her isn't
it Chris for her birthday you're taking
her to a show that you like that she's
never heard before you romantic bastard
you has never had the pleasure in
general or just having heard our show
and I thought we could change that
tonight I'm not sure she's prepared for
how much he's about to hear about anal
sex and Liam Neeson's [ __ ] but hopefully
she'll be willing to forgive me as David
Bowie would sing happy birthday to her
and heaven would give us his sexiest
dance his sexiest dance not just your
usual [ __ ] sexy dance this has got
to be your sexiest dance ever I don't
even know what you're talking about
take off the trippity that's right put
them on the glass Kevin put them on the
glass
thanks for only I was a funny Chris well
I think we can arrange for mr. Bowie to
wish happy birthday to salsa who's never
heard this bit before it has no idea
what we're doing miss Elsa right there
she salsa how are you
just the cabinet being oh you have no
taste and radio can we hit her a little
Bowie happy birthday to you we'll take
you where you like it happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you
[Music]
but I hope that you enjoy happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you that is the
worst birthday present ever watching a
dude and a hockey jersey catch his own
jism in his mouth yeah incorporate
touching me in the dance I'm not sure I
care for that I like it for support
[Music]
myself I mean we also get emails from
all around the world each and every week
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions well
speaking of emails got a lot of emails
this week from people who are looking to
order Babylon t-shirts and Grammy
t-shirts up for a Christmas present
yes yeah let the listeners know if you
order this week I guarantee you will get
them in in the post and you will get it
by Christmas so good garmi strong
conference I love a gift it's a
beautiful shirt it is unless you're like
selsun have never heard the show before
they're like what the [ __ ] is this why
is John Henson and a hockey player on
this t-shirt why am i I don't even watch
wipeout
Danielle riots it's my very dear friend
Hannah's birthday on Saturday so it's
hoping you and chemica wish her happy
birthday from me I would give her a
present myself but she's an Amsterdam
and I'm in Vancouver oh I have not you
have never been dance right here in
California like cafes where you can go
and enjoy it socially with other people
like go into a pop bar I know but I've
been married for like almost 15 years I
found something that works I stick with
it yeah I guess so I don't need to go
traipsing around the world I thought
this would be fitting because we're both
avid avid HBO listeners Hannah turned me
on to the show in the first place
not to mention not to mention the fact
that I'm a huge stoner and Hannah's
favorite passion is sipping on bourbon
just like you and Kev I didn't bother to
ask her what her favorite impression was
cuz they didn't to ruin the surprise so
I'll ask you to give her a birthday
shout it in my favorite voice David
Lynch Danielle right from Amsterdam she
says please let me know if there's
anything I can do to increase the
chances of this being read on this
weekend's show well be nude photo you
included Danielle really did help I want
to let you know that hello happy
birthday to Hannah in Vancouver I
understand there's a lot of men up there
who chop down trees
congratulations on that
Vancouver that's in Canada isn't it okay
then happy birthday and don't forget I
can't remember
there you go this next team backup from
Wayne Clark in Gosport UK he says
longtime listener of the show I hope you
guys will eventually come to the UK
we're gonna try to get there next year
oh yeah it's very nice yes I've been
there too we just haven't rubber brought
the show there right I thought you guys
would like to see this Hulk toy i won
from one of those crane machines you
find at the fair it says it's official
merchandise on the label but I'm not so
sure could you please take a look at the
enclosed photographs and give me your
thoughts Wayne Clark let's take a look
at the first picture this is something
he wanted one of those one of those
gravity machine deals I guess it looks
it looks legitimate enough although this
region looks a little bulbous to me can
we see the second pick that Wayne sent
along yeah I'm not sure if that's
official Hulk merchandise or not it
should be man it's what we all look for
but it's never there these guys finally
crack the code with an enormous green
[ __ ] you know they were sitting around a
marketing go what kids want in the hole
huge dick sir the massive dick give that
man a raise well I think must be
official then this next email email is a
creepy clown request so I'm guessing I'm
guessing it's creepy clown Tom
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this creepy clown request
comes from Adam in Baton Rouge Louisiana
holy [ __ ] man oh I got aunty Adam rights
you make Monday mornings more bearable
with Hollywood babble-on I would like to
request that lucious the stuttering pimp
would make a good creepy clown
for those of you who didn't listen to I
guess it was last week's show America
has fallen in love with lucious the
stuttering family as we all have lucious
is a character in trapped in the closet
the multi chaptered artist
musical soap opera by legendary woman
urinator honor our Kelly lucious is a
pimp in the story played by r kelly as
are most of the characters but he has an
unfortunate speech impediment Lucas
lucious rather is a stutterer for those
of you who aren't familiar I brought in
the the clip from last week see here
lucious singing about the fact that he
is missing some money and the girls need
that work overtime to make up for his
losses and you can hear the the stutter
is pretty self-evident
now Pamplemousse is they have a loss and
somebody gotta pay the cross one of you
this has been coming up
I ain't no dummy
[ __ ] better have my
[Music]
money money y'all know what I'm saying
Adam thinks that would make me an
effective creepy clowns Armstrong on
math do did you [ __ ] y'all know what I'm
saying every week we like to say goodbye
to some people in show business who have
put in the time they've entertained us
for years and they're passing makes this
world a little sadder place every week
we say goodbye to them in the Tinseltown
steps
[Music]
they will be missed they will indeed
this week's Tinseltown sniff is a
legendary influential guitarist named
Mickey guitar baker Mickey Baker was a
hard-working session man in the the
beginnings of rock and roll in the 1950s
worked with Ray Charles and Ruth Brown
and the Drifters he was a really in
demand session guy and eventually he got
together with one of his guitar students
a woman named Sylvia Vanderpool and they
formed a group called the Mickey and
Sylvia in 1955 they had one big smash
hit called love is strange in 1957 was
when that came out became a top
billboard song for those who aren't
familiar with it you may remember it
from the movie dirty dancing here's a
little taste of love is strange
[Music]
I see Sharon Stone walking through a
casino when I hear that oh that's right
yeah from casino yes I mean cuz see when
Marty Scorsese kind of reappropriation
song because it definitely belonged to
dirty dancing yeah that's the one that
does for me now it's the slow-mo on
Sharon Stone and and Robert De Niro's
watching it so ya know shot
that's a great song man I didn't know
that and it reminds me of Jennifer
grades original nose that's right I can
see here they're dancing trying to keep
her nose up a little head quivering
under the weight of it and just just
doing that cha-cha dancing so Mickey
passed away this week at the age of 87
years old Oh big bucket away we also
like to highlight some showbiz
celebrities who are able to get out of
the way of their own egos each and every
week to segment we call Hollywood
helpers quite a refractory period you
have there yeah I'm very pleased to say
that this week's Hollywood helper is
none other than TV's Batman Adam West
yeah my buddy Adam drew what happened
this is the kind of guy he is
and I knew a little bit about this story
before it happened but the video reached
the internet this week there's a guy in
the Batman collectors community and we
kind of know each other a little bit
named Mark Hardiman and I had always
heard of mark I met him once I think
when Adam got his star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame he came down to see it
happen but he lives in San Francisco
he's a fireman there saves lives
he's known amongst the Batman collectors
like myself for having one of the I
think there's only two that exist
original sets of Batman arriving
costumes from the 60s show he's got the
real deal now I didn't know this about
mark but apparently he's been he's had
some really tough times as of late the
past couple of years he had twin boys
both in
when they were toddlers one passed away
from cancer and then 26 days later the
other one was diagnosed with autism
his twin his twin sons so as you could
imagine it's been a dark time in their
household that there that he said I met
him once he's an amazing guy and a
fireman and he's really been putting on
a brave face and just doing what he
needs to do to keep his family together
anyway Adam West heard about this and
apparently decided to take upon himself
to go visit mark and his wife at their
home as surprised them and they set up a
deal with a video production company
that told mark that they were going to
do a piece on Batman collectors and his
costumes and stuff and then Adam was
just gonna show up and knock on the door
so here's the video of Adam showing up
at their house it's pretty cool here's
here's what's great US market sherry
been through some rough times and I hope
that my visit gives them some kind of
joy or fun or something to talk to the
neighbors about I'm not sure
[Music]
cool so why don't you just take us
through
[Music]
I'm looking for my cape and cowl
[Music]
yeah pretty cool what is fun Yahoo just
put it up on their site you can go to
yahoo.com and they've got a little piece
there where they show and I guess it's
called ultimate surprises or something
where they try to make people's lives
it'll be better by surprising them with
something and that was a little story
there so pretty cool and that's really
really touching that's cool imagine man
like her reaction is pretty authentic
yeah and then mark - I mean they were
both blown away by the fact that they
should be showed up at their house you
know could you imagine Bruce Wayne
really showed up your house and was like
I want my cape and cowl yeah that [ __ ]
is fine sadly I heard Adam pocketed some
[ __ ] on the way out I know it's truly
rip them off every week we take a look
that at stuff that just falls through
the cracks whether it's television or
film hundreds of pairs of eyes look at
these projects before they reach the
audience and yet still somehow these
mistakes get through every week we like
to salute them with [ __ ] that should not
be this week's email comes from Ross he
says since we're at the beginning of the
holiday season I don't think there's any
[ __ ] that should not be better than this
little gem from the rankin/bass classic
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer oh it's a
classic that I've seen this every year
I've been alive
so I dozens of times I've seen it one of
the first programs as a child that I was
like there's something for me because I
identified with the bum ball sure
bumbles bounce
Hermey the elf of course doesn't want to
be a toymaker
hmm I want to be a dentist excellent
wants to be a day and there's the head
elf in this this piece is the dick dick
he's like hermie what are you talking
about you want to be a dentist those
toys that's how the guy talks right
except in this scene something happens
horrible in this scene where suddenly
his voice changes mid-scene and no one
can explain it and I never noticed that
until this guy pointed this out and
brought this clip to my attention
they're singing for Santa they're about
to sing we are Santa's elves the
six on hmm and the head elf who's a dick
if I didn't mention it yeah we're gonna
do that and then come back he's just
he's just just a big homo I don't know
what's going on it's just what's
happening here's the clip from Rudolph
the red-nosed reindeer now let's try out
the new rankin/bass you have one job
that's to move little clay things and
make people's voice come out of him and
then match the voices up the little clay
things could you imagine how many kids
in the hwacha would be like his voice
changed mommy don't be ridiculous
drink your eggnog with rum in it that's
what my mom always said and I gladly did
this week we also take a look at a list
actors who've given less than a list of
performances with exquisite acting Risa
Russell is this week's exquisite actor
Theresa Russell was a big star in the
late 70s early 80s Black Widow with
Debra Winger she starred in that she
mates
she killed that's right she was in the
miniseries blind ambition she did a
bunch of movies with her at the time
husband Nicolas Roeg she worked with him
a bunch but she was also known as Denise
Richards mom in wild things if you ever
saw that film which famously features
the threesome with Neve Campbell Denise
Richards and Matt Dillon that's what
that movie is probably best known for
okay this comes from Kyle in Oklahoma
who says you need to appreciate Debra
excuse me
Teresa Russell's performance in this by
the tender way she treats her daughter
Denise Richards in this scene Denise
Richards is visibly upset and Teresa
Russell as the mother comes in to ask
her why she's crying
here's this week's exquisite acting what
is it I'm missin too sometimes
no you don't he didn't have to kill
himself Kelly could repeat for the
headline he didn't have to kill himself
Kelly usually have to watch a porn movie
to get that level of acting here let me
make you feel better Kelly
bing-bong someone ordered Pete Pete this
one of my favorite segments of the week
is when people take my buddy Kevin Smith
and put him in inappropriate places via
the magic of Photoshop it's known as
Kevin
[Music]
let's see what's kept in this week this
week we take a look at the history of
Kevin's career not as a screenwriter and
director as many of you may know him
best but as an actor a lot of you don't
know that Kevin started out as a child
actor here's Kevin in his very first
role I believe it was playing the role
of Elliott in et I don't know if you
guys knew that Kevin was Nevin as a book
it was actually the childhood Chum of ET
the extra-terrestrial in the Steven
Spielberg classic I did not know that
you had that role Facebook of me at age
14 yeah you you were young little if you
look real closely notice that you look
good in overalls you should think about
that as a look kevin of course his
career blew up after that he went on to
work with many directors including john
landis not many people know that he was
the best friend to David not in an
American Werewolf in London yeah they
are on the Moors stay off the Moors and
then Kevin as an actor grew and of
course he worked for many many years
most recently you probably have seen him
in looper with Bruce Willis
have you seen that film Willis looks
like you'd enjoy choking the [ __ ] out of
you in that scene I can't imagine why
but those are from Philly Reynolds and
Jeremy Z that's this week's Kevin let's
take a look at the HBO headlines
[Music]
this week's HBO headlines well it's just
been a it's just she's just the gift
that keeps on giving it's crazy dude I
mean normally I don't hear about her
until I come here but even this week
it's been so bad even I heard about
[Applause]
[Music]
first there was Liz and Dick yeah and as
if that wasn't bad enough this week we
found out that early Thursday morning at
4 a.m. a allegedly drunken Lindsay Lohan
was in a nightclub in Manhattan called
the club Avenue where reportedly she had
followed a guy named Max George who's in
the band The Wanted she has a crush on
him so she followed him to that Club
that's why she was there and reportedly
she had a drunken altercation with a
woman there and on the way out of the
club she punched the woman in the face
parole violation though well don't get
me wrong the the penal justice system
frowns on punching people in the face
when you're on probation absolutely and
she may have to face the consequences
here in Southern California for that but
I thought it was interesting as the more
I found out about this the woman that
she punched was a woman named Tiffany
Mitchell according to sources who is
known as a well-known psychic should not
see it coming that was my thought also
she claims that moments before the brawl
a friend of hers was before the brawl
she's just like
just couldn't get all the way fast
enough a friend of hers Tiffany
Mitchell's friend heard Lyndsey low and
call her a [ __ ] gypsy because this
woman followed Lyndsey into the club
yeah
claiming it sounds like a [ __ ]
daytime soap opera claiming that she had
something important to tell Lyndsey she
had her reading to give her so she
approached Lindsey's table and said I
want to give you a psychic reading and
like any sane person lindsay lohan said
get the [ __ ] away from my table [ __ ]
gypsy this isn't the Magic Castle get
away from me I'm busy down in Grey Goose
and trying to get the guy from The
Wanted's [ __ ] inside me I'm not here to
have you read my tea leaves so she told
her to get lost and that's when the
altercation happened the friend heard
her say [ __ ] gypsy under her breath
so the friend wheels around cost Lindsay
Lohan a [ __ ] how dare she hope she call
her a drunk and told her that Liz and
dick sucked she said everyone knew that
well that's when [ __ ] went down and
Lindsay on her way out apparently bit
this girl in the eye and then got into
her SUV door in the eye and then got in
her SUV and took off and the cops had to
chase down the SUV and pull her over and
that's where they arrested her on the
run on the run that she's taken up to
leave the scene of the crime quite a bit
longer notice and now she's got to go
away for something like this correct
well here's the thing she's claiming
she's been set up that she never hit the
girl now the girl who first of all she's
got two strikes against her in my book
first she's a [ __ ] psychic in other
if you guys know this or not but there's
no such thing as a [ __ ] psychic
secondly this woman Tiffany Mitchell has
hired Gloria Allred to be her attorney
now Lindsey didn't punch her she should
get a chance to after this I my opinion
and Lindsey says the whole thing's a
setup that she thought they were trying
to steal her purse as gypsies will do
I've seen enough movies to know and the
whole thing was a shakedown they're
trying to cash in a civil lawsuit to try
to get some money out of Lindsey but she
claims that she never punched her and
she will be vindicated she claims
because she's hiring a private
investigator to find out what's going on
with this gypsy ring of Bebe's [ __ ] of
them dude all I have to say is thinner
and that's to be honest I've been
insulting gypsies for years hoping
hoping one of them would say thinner and
it doesn't [ __ ] whatever happened I'm
at one that was like even fatter oh what
a great curse that would yeah right
Lindsey was booked around 4:00 a.m.
Thursday morning she was released about
four hours later we got a picture of her
I was looking for the mugshot we
couldn't find it we got a picture of her
coming out of the police station at
least here is Lindsey not the first time
she was sandwiched between two black
guys by the way
Oh oh now you got sympathy for now you
feel bad everybody's moaning share time
so we're gonna have to wait and see how
this shakes out but just being arrested
alone could violate her probation come
on man that you smash that 18-wheeler
while she was driving the car she lied
to the cops I mean she is a non-stop
[ __ ] or content generator that's true
we have to send to her residual check
when this is all over that by the way
more crime news and whatever with
Lindsay Lohan what hurts me is when
there's some ones who work who I
actually enjoy and respect
unlike Lindsay's this Liz and Dick show
was awful but there is an another woman
got into legal trouble this week who has
given me hours and hours of real genuine
pleasure and entertainment pornstar
Brianna Banks was in the news this week
she was busted for DUI at a McDonald's
drive-through news Undercovers Mayor
McCheese oh my goodness you're not
driving well by the way
[ __ ] alan tudyk too by the way you see
that record Ralph have you seen that
record Ralph no he plays a character
called King candy in that thing you know
King candy talks oh my goodness I can't
Andy oh yeah what a shame
I got a phone [ __ ] Disney I got a
phone just saved a lot of money hiring
me for that true man who cheaper than
too thick that's right anyway she was
busted in a McDonald's drive-through for
drunken driving hello you talk wasting I
do
apparently she had an accident just
before she offered to get some grub at
McDonald's okay and the woman who was in
the accident with her said I think that
one always [ __ ] up so she called the
cops and said this woman was under the
influence I believe this little
fender-bender she had and so the cops
show up at the depth at McDonald's where
she's spotted and they pull her over in
the drive-thru and it turns out they
according to the sobriety test like that
proves anything she was under the
influence
we've got her her mug shot and her we
got her at her at work and then her in
her mug shot among shots are always
disappointing aren't they unless they're
Nick Nolte's mug shots then they're
always better than the real thing but
yeah sadly Brianna she's she loses a
little luster when she's down there and
they in the police precinct those of you
who don't know Brianna's work you may
remember from such films as party mouth
[ __ ] adventures of doctor fellatio
but flossed chronicles was another film
she was in my father's large name fire
in the hole anally submerged semen
slippers by the way these are all actual
films honey I blew everybody PSA your
asses in her hands and her math perhaps
her most famous work creme de la face
speaking of bad mug shots the girl who
played Eric's older [ __ ] sister on
that 70 show Lisa Robin Kelly she was
arrested again this week for assaulting
her 61 year old husband she's 42 he's 61
that's just unfair right there the 61
year old I should be able to get one of
his younger friends to step in for him
and the the Ring of Honor and defend
himself but she was arrested for abusing
her 61 year old husband ruff
run him up this was the same charge she
was arrested for just months ago but
wasn't the same guy it was her
ex-boyfriend and roommate at the time so
I'm guessing she's living with her
ex-boyfriend and her husband at the same
time had just beaten the [ __ ] out of
everybody here's a here's her mugshot
there's this is her before and after
here's her in that seven-day show
yeah yeah don't do drugs kids don't do
drugs
it feels good but it's not pretty that's
the most important part more crime news
Elmo has been accused by a third man now
this way oh yeah a third alleged victim
of Kevin Clash the voice of Elmo and
Sesame Street has come forward claiming
he was 16 in the year 2000 when Kevin
Clash would serve him wine and then
engage in sexual activity with him then
they would engage in various sexual
activities the accusers lawyer says that
he's been contacted by several other
alleged victims so this may not be the
last we hear of this story yeah what
happens do you think they go keep going
with Elmo do they pull them out of
rotation for a little while I think
they're to keep Elmo the character does
someone else will be voicing him that's
all because Sesame Street has said look
Elmo didn't do anything wrong as far as
we know maybe they'll be another person
that comes forward to say Kevin Clash is
ok the puppet Laura talked about dark
creepy horrible things this week it came
to light that Anna Nicole Smith's
six-year-old daughter is now a model for
Guess jeans her name is Danny Lynn
Birkhead you may remember the big ho
little girl was going on when she was
born just before Anna Nicole Smith
passed away and then who was the father
was at Howard case turn her lawyer was
it Larry Birkhead her then-boyfriend it
turned out that he did get custody and
like the father good father that he is
he immediately at 6 years old
put her into modeling she's now a model
for kids for guessed their line here's
some pictures of baby Daniel Lynn who is
posing for photos for guests guest jeans
six years old yeah well because they
ever made up and she's drunk Burke had
said about putting his daughter into
modeling Dannielynn has always looked up
to her mom's image I think is this well
yeah well she's the she really is a
great role model really when you think
about it I think this is kind of Daniel
Eames way of paying tribute to her mom
in her own special way well it worked
out so well for her Anna Nicole Smith
but all show business thing I can see
why you'd want to push your kid into it
maybe you can find a 97 year old man in
a wheelchair your daughter can marry two
and then don't really go work out just
fine Canadians hate Justin Bieber this
week once again America was at the
forefront of a trend and now Canada's
just getting around to it he was
performing at the Canadian Football
League's championship it's kind of their
Super Bowl of growing fan of the Grey
Cup yeah he was performing there and he
was put up on the jumbotron and everyone
in the stadium started to boo him they
say it got worse when he started
performing at halftime they started
booing them oh he was performing yeah it
was it was a mega show they did and he
was performing a couple numbers from his
record back bacon I think it's called I
can't remember but they started booing
him and apparently he felt very
depressed about the whole thing home and
native land and we don't want to by the
way Canada in case you're thinking of
shipping them out he's your [ __ ]
problem now while we're talking about
[ __ ] problems this is fast this is
awesome maybe my favorite story of the
week Angus T Jones who plays the half
man on Two and a Half Men
he made us man finally lost his [ __ ]
mind he made a video this week saying
that two and a Half Men the television
program that I believe of I'm not
mistaken you have to check my facts and
figures on this I think he gets three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
episode to film this show it might be
three eighths between 300 and 350 yes
that show that he is on and he says is
filth and he's urging people not to
watch it
he has joined a new church he has found
Jesus and he is now a member of the
forerunner Christian Church which is
affiliated with the seventh-day
Adventist Church is this generations
Kirk Cameron yes I love it every
generation gets one man finds God an
apparently part of the forerunner
tradition is you have to make a
testimony video for the church yet to
bare your soul and only while the the
leader of the church sits right next to
you and stares behaviour in your eyes
here's a little piece of Angus T Jones's
video talking about how well he's not
happy with his job anymore
if you watch he's stop filling your head
with still please it's it's you know
people say it's just entertainment
the fact that it's entertainment it's do
some research on the effects of
television and your brain and I promise
you you'll have a decision you'll have a
decision to make when it comes to
television and especially with what you
watch on television
[Music]
but it's bad news people don't watch two
and a Half Men he got lost in his own
narrative at one point like at the end
the last 15 seconds if you go back and
listen to it really don't mean anything
well you just at one point he's like
[ __ ] I lost the thread and he just
starts throwing in words you know why
cuz he's thinking [ __ ] they give me a
lot of money to be on that show I just
said it's filth and don't watch it I
told people not not to watch the show
that I'm on I got a theory man it's a
ploy he's like look I'm tired of being
the half man I want this show to be
three [ __ ] men three full men yeah
the only way it's gonna happen if I
forced their hand by telling them I love
Jesus Jesus is gonna be the [ __ ] half
man now man well later on in the video
we have time to play at all but he
claims that the enemy Satan is trying to
send his message through that sitcom
that particular one yes oh all bad
television and I have to agree with some
bad boy I've seen it too an F man and
that is [ __ ] the work of the devil
that's for sure
devil with a soundtrack that's what I
ever laugh track I've always called it
meanwhile Charlie Sheen has said that
the show is cursed
he weighed in yeah he said the show is
cursed yeah that's what it is Charlie
the show is cursed
now any to see John should feel bad that
Satan left the show and they hired
Ashton Kutcher so he really shouldn't be
upset anymore
Angus quickly issued a lengthy apology
the following day what a surprise
meanwhile during all this I guarantee
man [ __ ] Chuck Sheen blows up [ __ ]
the half man blows up Ducky's sitting on
a mailbox in the rain crying yeah this
[ __ ] guy just wants to earn his money
go home to his pretty television fine
head down and make the jokes I like the
checks without qualification I'm
grateful too and I had the highest
regard and respect for all the wonderful
people on Two and Half Men with whom I
have worked over and over with the past
ten years who have become an extension
of my family he writes his lawyer writes
I thank them for the opportunity they
have given and continue to give me and
the help and guidance I have and expect
to continue to receive from them please
don't please don't see what happens
[ __ ] tape star Kim Kardashian in a week
this week
[Applause]
[Music]
this week the Glendale City Council
Linda
Glenda those who were listening who
don't know Glendale California has a
large Armenian population yeah it's true
and Kim Kardashian is of Armenian
descent okay and so the City Council at
least some of the City Council this week
has suggested that they would like to
invite her to ride on their upcoming
float in the Tournament of Roses Parade
on New Year's Day [ __ ] somebody on video
and they'll put you on the parade float
yeah
City Councilman are on Najarian
suggested at a city council meeting that
she be invited to have one of the seats
on the float because she represents a
prominent Armenian American some of the
other council members like Dave Weaver
don't agree and he suggests they use
local high school students on the float
instead to truly represent people who
live in the City of Glendale a third
councilman suggested a compromise saying
they use local high school students who
have blown black guys on video that idea
was tabled apparently no one voted for
that one so it's going up for a vote
later this week but Kim Kardashian may
be invited to actually ride on the float
in the Tournament of Roses Parade
representing the City of Glendale even
though she doesn't live there she has
never lived there she's never been part
of that city they want to put her on the
float I just hope somebody explains to
her what ride the float means before the
day of the parade they're also
suggesting that putting wheels on Khloe
Kardashian and having Kim ride on top of
her
which kill two birds with one stone
you could just thethe ur Chloe to those
lines like they use of a Thanksgiving
Day Parade and Macy's and just pull her
down the plate parade route
Amanda Bynes is back in the news can you
believe it
[Applause]
[Music]
the audience is demanding the theme
songs now
where's your faith song amanda bynes who
has told everyone that she wants to be
left alone she's retired from acting
please give her her privacy posted on
Instagram this week that she could not
be happier with her turban I [ __ ] you
not she posted a picture of her in a
turban saying and I quote love my turban
here's a picture of Amanda Bynes
wearing a turban then she was walking
down the street in New York City and she
happened to cross a gathering of
paparazzi and she quickly panicked
because she said here we go again
they turns out they were waiting for
Justin Bieber so she hailed a taxi she
hopped in the taxi then she had the taxi
pull over about halfway down the block
she got out of the taxi walked back to
the photographers and started screaming
at them saying how inappropriate they
are and what they were doing was illegal
and they should leave him alone then she
hopped back in the taxi and she drove
away back to crazy [ __ ] town so she
wants to be left alone but apparently
she's still making her presence known in
New York City you know it's coming up on
our New Year's Eve show yes we do it
every year and of course this will be
the second year we give away the Chelsey
award which is the award for the year's
biggest talentless kuntum and last
year's winner Courtney Stodden is still
in the news because she is on that she's
in the running for this year she oh she
might be a repeat winner absolutely you
know hard it is to win back-to-back
couples therapy on vh1 apparently one of
her co-stars a guy named Nick Richie
claims that Courtney made sexual
advances to him while she was in the
house alone with him while they were
shooting the reality
show when she's married she didn't care
he says she even did it in front of Doug
Hutchinson her husband who seemed cool
with it he's creepy
yeah doing it got so bad that I had to
have a meeting with the producers to
tell her to stop because I didn't want
to go to jail she is only 17 years old
this guy also claims he tells the
Huffington Post that the entire
relationship is contrived Courtney
doesn't care about him but it's
Courtney's mom that is in love with Doug
and they said she had her daughter marry
him in order to be close to him and
she's now serving as her daughter's
manager / mom and their relationship to
be Doug and the mother apparently is
very close as well he also thinks she
may be doing drugs and have emotional
problems this side this fat Korean dude
sigh this Gangnam style this brought the
record the most-watched video ever in
the history of YouTube to be fair though
you've seen the video yeah it's
captivating man like first time ice I
think I saw it on equals 3 the first
time and I remember gon like Jesus who
would do this and who would do it is the
person that now has the most amount of
hits on you little taste of a little
taste of
[Music]
you're not doing the dance every other
[ __ ] jingle you're all over the place
touching yourself you want through the
Gangnam dance style he is enjoying his
success almost by the way almost a
billion views on YouTube yeah it's
approaching a billion views he is a he's
a very likable guy they say guy who was
very easygoing and he must be because
there is a restaurant in Koreatown here
in Los Angeles called soju town that has
recently changed their name here's what
the front of soju town looks like now
Gangnam style restaurant it's called SIA
said that he will not sue soju town for
changing their name of the restaurant to
Gangnam style
they never bothered to get his
permission but he said that he is
flattered because he thinks imitation is
the sincerest form of flattery he also
said in about a year I'm gonna be
needing a job as a busboy oh and he
wants to keep in good graces with the
owners of soju Tom he's probably he's
got so much money yeah I do totally that
song sold man like because that video
and [ __ ] isn't like number one single
rotor don't know which money he's making
I just hope I thought the way I heard
that story that was all his like it was
his song his video it all together hood
all that [ __ ] together man and again
it's like if you watch the video it's
it's a it's a good time it's well let's
not get nuts concerns me no worry going
on for me in that video when I watch it
what about those models were inhaling on
that fake snow and the one gross choking
on it it makes me very upset with all
due respect to Ben Affleck this is the
film of the year right so yeah [ __ ] Argo
hour go [ __ ] yourself
only John Goodman was in that oh wait a
minute he's in every fun speaking of
movies it's time for a sequence we like
to talk about where we can see into the
future we're like those psychics that
Lindsay Lohan punches we can tell you
movies that aren't even out yet that I
promise you will suck
[Music]
this week's movie that I guarantee you
will suck his starring Kellan Lutz of
the legendary Twilight series he's
already made a bunch of movies that suck
and now his next movie that will suck is
a film called tattwa just announced
Kellan Lutz will be starring in tattoo
uh he plays a guy with a rare blood type
that allows a special Inc to be tattooed
onto his body but when he wants to use
the items that are tattooed on his body
he can pull them off and they become
real that's [ __ ] from the comics they
stole that the tattooed man yeah yeah
yeah also from Green Lantern oh yeah so
wait that's the that's the premise of
the film he will pull tattoos off his
body and use them as weapons yeah but
more importantly it's going to suck I
think he is going also just to play
Tarzan yeah but more importantly he's
making a movie where tattoos come to
life and that's a good tattoo not the
one from Fantasy Island either no the
ones that are on his body Herve belli
shows off his body
anytime somebody with Herve Villechaize
movies that will suck how about TV shows
that will suck this week the Blues
Brothers TV show is becoming a reality
dan Aykroyd will star as Elwood blues no
word on who will be traveling alongside
of him this is gonna happen this is
gonna happen John Goodman yes who was in
Blues Brothers 2000 a Canadian based
production company has picked up the
rights to the Blues Brothers TV show
it's likely to be produced in Canada
then tried to be sold in America so
we're lucky the Border Patrol will hold
this in cash
and we'll never see the light of day in
America unlike Bieber who they let slip
through the traq cracks like there was a
tunnel or something Bieber got through
so wait it's not he's playing out would
fling Elwood apparently Elwood and Jake
or whoever our newly released from
prison at the beginning of the series
and Elwood's trying to find his father
since he grew up in an orphanage and
there'll be the quest of Elwood trying
to find his father and every week there
will be a brand-new musical number
featuring Elwood and the new Blues
Brothers Band
I just hope Kellan Lutz is in it I mean
I might look it's it's Dan Aykroyd
creation man let him have fun with it
whatnot but ya know he can it says he
gets maybe much to forgiving sir I mean
it says it's as if he created the Blues
Brothers yeah you know if he wants to go
deeper into it I guess like a no-brainer
to do an animated series you know what
I'm saying then you don't have to worry
about the how old
Elwood looks and stuff or the missing
yeah
Aykroyd said in order to kick off the
series before they get started he's
going to go to John Belushi's grave and
[ __ ] on it just to give it the
appropriate spirit of the project
doesn't get things going let's take a
dump on Belushi
I think it's appropriate Kevin and I are
both geeks that means every week we look
forward to talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of rumors flying around this week
about who's gonna be Batman in the new
Justice League movie you may have heard
Joseph gordon-levitt's name bandied
about well here's the thing a lot of
people were excited by the news and a
lot of people were disappointed by the
news it's kind of split there are some
cats who love The Dark Knight Rises so
we're like oh my god that means that the
last scene in Dark Knight Rises is a
teaser for Justice League movie because
that's technically Batman and then
they're a bunch of people who are like
that's not Bruce Wayne so it could never
be Batman right so people who were
excited and then the people who were
upset then the the excited people got
upset and the upset people got excited
because Joseph gordon-levitt's
representative said no it's not the case
it's never gonna have all of those
rumors so everything you read on the
Internet is once again lies don't
believe any of it except for this
because I read this on the internet
they're gonna do the next x-men movie
that's called x-men days of future past
bryan bryan singer is returning
we know that your past is amazing
storyline where there's the alternate
reality and [ __ ] will help them hunt it
down by the sentinels and should kitty
pryde an old wolverine team-up it's a
fan if they stick close to the original
source material it's one of the greatest
excellent stories ever told
I thought they were going to do the bull
moody blues album Days of Future past so
that's what they're gonna do nice and
white sad
[Music]
so it turns out they're gonna have money
they're being back is great that is good
news
very cool makhni doe and Professor
Xavier will be played by both Michael
Fassbender and James McAvoy oh that's
awesome man that means they're going up
the present and passwords but also Ian
McKellen and Patrick Stewart are also
returning as so you're gonna get both
versions James McAvoy going on at the
same time
that is tremendous yeah Jennifer
Lawrence will return his mystique really
yeah I'd rather see Rebecca remains
nameless but what do I know it's not
famous anymore is she should recover
remain and whose and nicholas hoult
played beast well done
Matthew Vaughn was the director of x-men
first hell of a segue and the reason I
bring his name up is because there's
been a lot of speculation on who's gonna
direct the Star Wars movies who's gonna
was gonna helm the next trilogy of Star
Wars movies my friend Kevin Smith's name
is even bandied about
[Music]
[Applause]
unless unless star wars 7 takes place on
the ice no what about a hockey
tournament between the rebellion and
honestly that would make sense me
because start war seven follow Star Wars
six return the Jedi where the rebels
beat the Empire right and it's done so
yeah nothing to do for the next three
movies except played hockey that's true
one of the names that has been bandied
about is Matthew Vaughn as we mentioned
was the director of x-men first class
and great job on that II also I like
kick-ass do we do a nice job on kicker I
love to kick ass and apparently tell me
kick ass to right isn't early season Bob
he's producing interest I don't know if
he directed or not anyway his buddy
Jason Fleming who was in snatch and also
in first class they've done nine films
together and so he was cornered in one
of these I don't around tables or
something being interviewed by somebody
and someone brings up Star Wars because
Matthew Vaughn's name had been just
tangentially attached as one of the
potential directors for Star Wars seven
to the next film and Jason Fleming [ __ ]
up big time in this interview he kind of
gives away the story here's a little
piece of video with a guy talking about
ahead Jason Fleming I think knows more
than than we do Matthew it's all about
installs essential cuz I could be like
be free films I'm sure I get the cool
Star Wars I'm sure it's gonna be
literally Fleming no I know on paper
doesn't know that much but I promise you
it's essential to the park so we'll see
it's my few interested that do you think
in what song father deal he gave it away
that looks like yeah Matthew wasn't to
be the direction of seven according to
his best friend who said that story in
the works unless it isn't
I mean first the first class is a really
good flick he did a really nice job with
that cast as well it's amazing how many
people are almost falling over
themselves trying to direct when these
Star Wars films you have a high
generation you know the Oh makers who
were a lot of people they asked a lot of
people Chris Nolan really I think
there's a it's big shoes to fill for
some cats other cats I believe obviously
up to the chance I think there's a
generation of filmmakers who would love
a shot at the Star Wars fans when they
take a look and the best geek news of
the week in my opinion is the fact that
the original 1966 Batmobile is going up
for auction right January Mary's January
19th in Scottsdale Arizona the want the
original the first the number one car
this is the hero car used on the series
this is George Barris his car that he
created the Batmobile This Is It this is
the only one his own this is his this is
the first one this is the one that was
used in all the hero shots on the TV
series in the feature film in 66 this is
this is the one this has never been sold
before he's had it in his possession
since the show went off the air in 1960
he takes it on tour and show he does
made a ton of money with it but I think
he's getting old down he realizes that
he might as well catch you like stole
glass so appreciate the money that's
gonna bring in and there's a ton of
replicas out there there there are there
are douchebags who will get married and
they will show up in a replica 1966
Batmobile and they look good here's a
picture one of those douche bags right
there they will they will get the
replica going and then they're very
impressive
but there's only one there's only one
original here's the this is George
Barris outside Waco but we go back to
the other picture you want to go back
she wore white
yeah she's wearing white hold we got
some fall
how much how much is the well here's the
question how much is the car going for
yeah there is a reserve price okay but
they won't reveal what it is
two hundred eighty five thousand are you
[ __ ] insane they asked the guy
barrett jackson's chief executive
officer Craig Jackson said let's just
say it's in the multi-millions he says
opening bid yes that's the reserve on
the Aston Martin that Sean Connery drove
in Goldfinger went for 1.5 million
dollars at all and that's not even
nearly as well known as this is gonna be
the most famous automotive enterprise
yeah right you were at Comic Con this
summer all of them out there under the
tent this thing's still some 45 50 years
later still gets a ton of attention it's
it's the gold standard yeah it's and if
you watch the cartoon Batman Brave and
Bold all of the Batman vehicles took
their their kind of highlights from the
highlights of that of that Batmobile
it'll always be the Batmobile to to
everybody yeah I could see that going
for it
so they have the original the one that
was yeah I'm thinking I think so so for
those of you who asked me what I want
for Christmas
look we reach hundreds of thousands of
people with this podcast you don't have
to have one [ __ ] rich guy in the
audience there has to be one guy who
stinking [ __ ] rich so there's the
wouldn't miss a few mil who wants to
give you your childhood back yes how
about something for the guy heart grow
two sizes too big right and I know last
week I asked for that Emma Stone sex
tape but this week this week I'm serious
this week I would really like someone to
buy me the Batmobile because I don't
have that kind of coin I mean I'm not a
big you know Hollywood mogul movie star
I didn't start my own universe I don't
have all of the 20 years of filmmaking
behind me with all of the legendary
films that people love I don't go don't
play to sold-out Sydney Opera House's
around the world doing my Q&A so I don't
have that kind of money people I'm just
a lowly hard-working radio DJ that's all
I am so if someone alert a lot to buy me
something special to prove I don't know
friendship or appreciation for years of
a partnership doing podcasts or things
that I'm saying there's enough there's
an opportunity here for love and mate
they should buy you that car and lastly
the mayor of Batman turkeys upset did
you know there's a city in Turkey called
Batman [ __ ] yes I want to live there
when I grow older it since I've always
wanted to be inside Batman it's in
southeastern Turkey and the mayor of
Batman has just announced they are suing
Warner Brothers and Christopher Nolan's
multi-million dollar lawsuit because
they say they were Batman first before
that I have no idea cuz you know why
it's [ __ ] Turkey let's sue them man
cuz you know Turkey was turkey first
that's right the burger predates you we
go all day Turkey
jive Turkey Hussein Ian Culkin
the pro-kurdish Democratic Society party
mayor of Batman has filed a lawsuit
against Warner Brothers and the
producers of The Dark Knight because he
says and I quote there is only one
Batman in the world
I guess he means his city I'm guessing
because I was gonna agree with him in
principle the American producers used
the name of our city without informing
us
he said now no one bothered to mention
him I guess that Batman has been around
since nineteen [ __ ] thirty nine you
wanted to file a lawsuit maybe you want
to do it at some time in the past
I don't know hundred years or so are you
sure that they're not finding the
lawsuit because they're like we have
seen this Dark Knight Rises and we do
not like the Batman voice what is this
with Batman taking a cheaters off we are
suing you for the breach of Batman hood
also he walks with leap and then puts on
leg brace and can kick bricks this movie
no word on whether they recognize the
Batman's been around since 1939 but it
may some people say have something to do
with the fact that the Dark Knight just
passed the 1 billion dollar mark at the
box office and perhaps Batman Turkey
wise a little something something they
wouldn't wet their wings with something
they want some of the white meat that's
right
Warner Brothers says they're looking
into the case but they have not
presented their their defense yet here's
the thing part of the suit according to
the mayor of Batman Turkey is that they
believe that Batman the character has
caused an unusually high number of
unsolved murders in their town and a
high female suicide rate because of
Batman because everyone so bummed out
that there's this character running
around as the name of their city they're
killing themselves
Batman would hate that he would I'm
guessing the women in that town er
upset because they live in [ __ ]
Turkey so we'll wait and see what
happens but I'm guessing Warner Brothers
will fight this suit with enormous
amount of strength yeah every week we
take a look at a musical question that
answers something Kevin Smith is trying
desperately to figure out how big is
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] Lam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big in audition for cop-out but sadly
that project already had a huge dick in
it Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big if the
reason Batman had to take 8 years old
and why he walked with a limp Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when he
masturbates it's considered a threesome
a lot it's a lot of flesh there Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Clarissa can't explain it all yeah
that's a good one
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big don't make
him horny you wouldn't like him when
he's horny Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
when Liam pokes you on Facebook you walk
funny for a week Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big the punchline to this joke will
be on next week's show Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big
an old lady was once seen standing on
its tip throwing a diamond necklace into
the ocean Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that lifetime made a TV movie called
Liam and dick Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that it actually got back together
with Taylor Swift
and she said it would never happen
and lastly me in it what Wow I'm oh so
bird up pull up in your battery
compartment go it's small wonder
obviously
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's why
lucious the pimps this [ __ ] y'all know
what I'm saying
[Music]
Hollywood is you have a good time
disease man thank you as always for
coming out to see us we truly do
appreciate it we off next week we're
here we're off next week next week but
we're back to exact the 15th on the 22nd
yes and don't forget New Year's bad
believe is on sale now and the tickets
are scarce so make sure you grab them up
I can't thank you enough for selling us
out again man thanks for being here this
evening but that is it for Hollywood
babble-on this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm
rep Carmen babble the [ __ ] off everybody
good night ladies and gentlemen get up
you